In higher level programming languages
there often isn't a distinction between
linked lists and arrays.
There's just a list that
has the properties of both.
However questions about
these two data structures
are fairly common in interviews, so
it's important to know the difference.
Again, the main distinction is that each
element stores different information.
In both cases a single
element will store a value.
Or the actual information.
So if you have an array or
linked list of numbers,
the value will be a single number.
If you have an array or
linked list of string values,
then each value will contain a string.
In this case we're just
going to stick with numbers.
Now, in both cases we store
one other type of information.
But that type is different.
In an array we would store
a number as an index.
You can get the next element
by querying the array for
the element at index one in this case.
Let's clear this out and focus.
Just some linked lists for now.
In a linked list, we store a reference
to the next element in the list.
In many languages this will look like
assigning the actual next element
as a property of this element.
Way down at the hardware
level your element
actually has some space dedicated for
it in memory.
These are representing
the memory locations.
So in this case, the next component is
actually storing the memory address
of the next element,
while this element is
storing null because it doesn't
point to anything else.
The nice thing about the system is
that it's pretty easy to insert and
delete elements.
Adding an element is going to look
something like this, we really just need
to change the next reference to
point to the new object and done.
There's a quick trick you
need to remember though
if you delete the next reference and
replace it with a new object.
You'll lose your reference to this
object, you should always assign your
next pointer for this element before
you assign your next pointer for
this element, so you don't lose your
reference to this one down here.
Now everything looks great.
Note that insertion takes constant time
in this case since you're just shifting
around pointers and not iterating
over every element in the list.
Removing an element is going
to look pretty similar, so
I'm not even going to go over that now.
There's also something
called a doubly linked list
where you have pointers to the next
element and the previous element.
The rules are pretty similar for
a doubly linked list,
except you can traverse the list
in both directions now.
Again, you need to be careful not
to lose references when adding or
removing elements but it's easier than
performing these operations on an array.